Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on here?
This is Robin. We are picking back up again with the swords of X event.
And this sees the return of one of my favorite villains of all time and the
history of Marvel comics.
You guys know exactly who I'm talking about.
The downside of this is we see him once.
That's all we get. So what we initially have here is an Emissary, right?
An invitation to a contest of worlds, basically saying,
we invite you to see the,
the battle between the forces of a Rocco and the forces of Kakowa. Now,
a lot of the guys have kind of been wondering,
or at least kind of express a little bit of confusion in terms of what's going
on here to kind of sum this all down the nature of what's going on with XO
swords that are, I guess, 10 of swords, whatever you want to call it.
The whole reason why this is taking place is because apocalypse,
when he opened the gate,
the external gate that basically allows access between Coca-Cola and other
world. His goal was to use that gate to access a Rocco,
to rescue his wife and his children, the four horsemen,
and then bring them back to cacoa and basically unite his family,
what he ended up discovering.
And what we discovered is that what you also had going on were called the forces
of Amman and the forces of amaranth managed to breach their own realm.
And that eventually they were taken over by the four horsemen.
So the four horsemen lead the army of Ammon.
And so when apocalypse entered other world with the intention of reuniting his
family, that he discovered his family had basically become bad guys, right?
Like his,
his kids basically became villains and they were leading this army and they
intended to basically use the cocoa Wingate that granted access to other world
to pass through that gate,
into Coca-Cola and then conquer cacoa and the rest of the world. Right?
So it was, it's kind of like, you know, I want to get my kids back. Oh my God,
they're villains.
And the whole reason why this matters is because in order to settle the affair,
right,
in order to basically keep like all out war between the forces of Precoa and the
forces of a Rocco emerging on Saturday, and basically created this contest,
right? Created this, this whole great big, huge tournament.
And whoever wins will be the one who decides or who gets what it is that they
want. Right? So if the four horsemen, if apocalypse has kids win the tournament,
then they lead the army of [inaudible]. If the forces of Coca-Cola win,
then the army of amaranth, whatever happens to them, happens to them.
And that's why we are where we are right now should just a quick little
synopsis, kind of a quick explanation. I get this.
Some of the guys are a little confusing.
It's the nature of going through Jonathan Hickman's work kind of piece by piece
is that it's one of these things where he reads much better in trade. It's much,
much better to read Jonathan Hickman stories when it's all done and you go and
you get the trade paperbacks, right. It makes everything make a lot more sense.
But the, uh,
the Emissary has basically appeared here to mad Jim Jasper's in the crooked
market, right. And basically saying,
this is your invitation to show up here to this tournament to become a part of
it, right. To kind of watch everything unfold.
And that's the last time we see Jim Jasper's in this comic,
but here's the funny thing about this, right?
Here's the funny thing about what Hickman's going to end up doing here.
Jonathan Hickman, with, with Matt, Jim, Jasper's it could go one of two ways,
right? We could see Matt Jasper's pop off.
We could see him just lose his mind and this crazy display of power in the next
issue. We may not see him again for another five issues. Right.
It could be that we see him in the background during the whole tournament.
And then we don't actually see him do anything for another 50 issues.
There's no telling with Jonathan Hickman, right.
We have no idea Jonathan Hickman, right. For the long game. Right.
He writes for the conclusion of the story.
So it's kind of the nature of the beast, right? It's the nature of the,
and so because of that, the next thing is that the, uh,
the Emissary visits that came of sub uh, civil life,
and then of course visits the inferior at the ever forge.
Now the inferior and really the fear of themselves,
the fact that there's more than one is kind of terrifying.
The fury are wildly powerful beings, right?
So to kind of give you guys a little bit of an explanation here,
when imagine Jasper's originally appeared in Marvel comics,
he was part of a universe called earth two 38.
And this was a universe where he basically killed all the superheroes,
but Jim Jaspers didn't do it on his own. Instead,
what he did is he used his powers to work reality, to create the fury.
And the fury was a being that had the ability to adapt to anybody's powers and
then overcome them. It's how the fury was well, a defeat,
Jim Jasper's from the main Marvel universe.
When the fury showed up inside the main Marvel universe,
or at least the first time that fury killed him,
that the two of them actually ended up coming back.
There's a story that we haven't covered called X-Men die by the sword.
I think where Jim Jasper's comes back. But,
but the whole idea here is that the fury realized that the only way the Jim
Jasper's powers work is if the universe to alter.
And so we took him to where the earth two 38 universe was out before it was
destroyed and then basically obliterated him, right?
Because he realized that in this giant empty space where there is no matter the
Jim Jasper's is powerless. Right?
So the fact that there's like an entire place here full of furious is kind of
nuts. Weapon forgers.
They create like these basically basically like these unbreakable weapons and
all of reality, like in the entirety of the multi-verse because rubber,
what we're dealing with here are multi multi-verse Haitians.
People from different universes can access these different places,
crooked market apocalypse from like, you know,
the age of apocalypse universe could access this and like characters somewhat
the days of future past universe assess this, uh, feasibly.
If they decided to include it, the Marvel cinematic universe,
Dr. Strange could travel to this place, right. It's kind of, kind of bunker.
So we're dealing with things on a much larger scale. These aren't planets,
these are whole universal territories, right?
Little pocket dimensions also got the Holy Republic of the Fe.
You've got the floating kingdom of Roma, Roma, Regina.
This is basically Merlin and Roma.
They were previously the ones who ruled over other world before the events of
the incursions, the death of the, of the whole, uh, captain Britain court.
And the fact that they just kind of ended up going to war with each other,
but in their absence, it allowed Saturday to take over control of other world.
And that's why she is where she is. But nonetheless, you know, following these,
these kinds of emissaries or this Emissary that's sent out,
and these invitations that are given to these various people,
we pick up with what are called the foul and fair courts.
And this is basically a kind of coming together of these various courts.
Some of which we see here, some of which we don't, for example,
you don't see Jim Jasper's here. Who's considered part of the foul,
probably because he's just like, I have other things to do.
Besides show up here, you see the furious who were here.
They're considered part of the fair court Hickman doesn't really play it solid
in so far as saying the fear court are good guys, the foul court are bad guys.
We're not really given a, given a kind of knocked down X.
And that way we can kind of assume maybe it is,
but historically Merlin is a Dick. And the fact that he's of the,
of the foul court kind of makes sense,
but Rome has been a little weird too sometimes. And so there's been a time,
a few times where she's been a little bit villainous and her actions.
And so again, it kind of seems to follow that ideology, but again,
we're not given like an actual definitive instead,
the whole purpose behind the assembling of this court is basically the blights
of blight spokes to be allowed access across like any of the dimensions that
they want to. Now,
we're not really given a whole lot of information about the blight spoke.
And in fact, this is all we really seem to see of them, right?
You got sheriff geo white chapel of the blight spoke, and that's really it. Uh,
their request is denied and that's, that's really all you get here,
but it's a little bit of a kind of a court thing,
but the reason why Hickman does this is because this will be important later on
down the line, right. As a reason why he gives us this.
And so for the most part, we can kind of take this a little bit of a scene.
We can sit it on the back burner and then come back to it at a future point in
time. Uh, but the,
the important thing to kind of come out of this is that at the ethic inclusion
meeting, essentially,
you end up having Saturday and who asks the current horseman who were there, uh,
you know, like pestilence and war,
all you are Rocco forces currently prepared to engage in this conflict and the
answer's. Yes. And then of course she asked him, he brought it,
what about your forces? Like Precoa and he's like, they're on their way. Right?
So basically this is a coming together of the warriors, right.
They're all basically arriving in other world.
And then the tournament will commence after that. Right. And so when,
what we end up doing here is transitioning to cacoa and apocalypse talking to
all the, the sword bears. Right. And he gives like the worst speech ever.
He's like, okay, guys, don't die. Because if you do,
then you're going to come back and some weird twisted version. All right,
let's go. And that's basically it. And instead, you know, the,
the statements kind of like, I mean,
you should kind of give us a little bit of like a pep talk, right? I mean,
you know, it's like, like literally like, well, like, I mean, can you like,
it couldn't hurt, right? If you give us some kind of a pep talk and so he does,
and it's actually this Epic, I have talked, right? He says like sword bears,
most of you are mutant.
You have tasted the sweetness of immortality and evolution of our people,
meaning the fact that they can die and always come back.
Now we step into the other world. We're all, realities are one.
And your defeat will mean the death of Coca-Cola the death of this earth and the
death of you as you are now never to return. So when you draw your sword,
you must not fight like a human who stands to lose a few years of toil,
but like a mutant who stands to lose forever and paradise for,
if you do not, you will not be the first immortals I will have watched die.
It's a crazy, it's a really, really cool thing. It's a pretty Epic speech.
Right. It's a pretty awesome speech there. Yeah.
So what we ended up doing is picking up with these various forces of glaucoma
and a Rocco all showing up here. Right.
And initially it starts with captain Britain showing up here along love rain
cable. So on, they all basically teleport in at the same time, but when they do,
it's kind of like, okay, like immediately on their guard. Right.
Because they don't know if they're teleporting in here and the battle
immediately starts.
They don't know if they're teleporting in here and there's going to be a lot of
pomp and circumstance. Right. A great, big, huge kind of procession or,
you know.
Welcome to the 10 of X event, you know, and so on and so forth.
You know, like you got Michael buffer there, you know.
In this side of the ring, standing at five 42, weighing some ridiculous number.
Because his bones are covered in an unbreakable.
Metal Wolverine.
I don't really know if that's, that's, that's what we're going to get. Right.
I think it'd be awesome if like Michael buffer showed up here and offered a kind
of speech, but I think it'd be pretty cool, but Saturday,
and finally makes her appearance and basically tells everybody you guys need to
chill. Right. You know, like, like relax, the tournament's not starting yet.
It will start soon.
Your fellow combatants are going to be arriving here and it'll be a chance for
you guys to meet. So head to your quarters, they've all been prepared for you.
And when they arrive there, they're all given their respective cards.
Do you remember these were cards that were created by Saturn EAN explicitly for
them,
but the cards do not necessarily mean what they appear to be on their faces.
For example, you end up having cable.
Who's given the card of the fool and it doesn't mean that cable is an actual
full, even though we think that's what it means. Instead.
It's the journey of the fool, which is to say he doesn't know everything yet,
but he will learn a lot as time goes on.
This really kind of seems to be around it.
That way of John and Hickman saying the powers of cable are going to expand or
cable's own individual story is going to become a lot more grandiose than it
currently is. But then of course, you end up having apocalypse who reads his,
gets angry and throws it away.
And so what he ends up doing is traveling to meet Saturday.
And this common conversation between these two is wildly intriguing.
And that's what makes Hickman's X's swords.
So cool is because you see characters meeting whom you would never see meet
under any other circumstance and watching how they interact is really
intriguing. For example,
like Saturday Dean was never really the most powerful character ever.
It wasn't until she took over other world and then started using all the magic's
at its disposal to, to, to utilize, you know, to, to really rule this place.
This should became as powerful as she is prior to this,
she was basically a figurehead, but she was the Omni Versal magistrate.
She was not on par with like the living tribunal or somebody like that.
She just kind of played more of a gubernatorial role in relation to like how the
multi-verse functions. You know,
if you kind of broke it down into different positions,
she played more of a governing body, uh, with regards to the living tribunal,
he played like the power source. Now,
neither one really associated with the other.
It's not like you would see meetings of the Omni vessel development court and
like the living tribunals out there in the third row, watching it all go down,
you would never really see that instead. It was just,
it was kind of doing its own thing.
It was part of this wildly intricate hierarchy of how the multi-verse,
how its form and function is maintained. The funny thing about that though,
is the Omni development court was sometimes acknowledged and sometimes ignored
by Marvel comics, depending on who the writer was. You know, for example,
you never really, you hadn't seen it for like,
I want to say it didn't appear for like a decade until you got to the
incursions, right? I mean,
you had Spiderman UK and you had a few appearances here and there,
but like in those five years that Marvel was leading up to the secret Wars.
You saw it multitude of multitude of times prior to that,
you'd never saw it at all. Right.
And you probably wouldn't have known it existed unless you were reading the
right kind of comics.
And even then it didn't really appear all that often in Excalibur.
So it's one of these interesting things.
That's kind of the nature of the nature of how it all works.
Models never really consolidated it. They never really kind of explained, like,
what's the nature of the Omni Rosso development court in comparison to the
living tribunal does like the one above all, is he part of this? Like, was he,
was he the one that kind of engineered that?
How does it compare to like the fulcrum and the Neil diamond comics for the
Eternals? We don't really know. Right.
We're not really given an explanation here. Well,
the apocalypse showing up here and basically meeting her,
the question is I don't really like what, what I'm seeing here. Right? Like,
I don't really like what's going on. I don't really like this game.
You're playing answer me. Right?
Like what's the meaning of these taunts of all this nonsense,
but notice Saturnian, doesn't really take him seriously. Now,
one of the big things about our character about Saturn Dean's character
historically is she always had a kind of arrogance, right.
There was always a kind of arrogance about her in the sense of I'm above you.
I'm way above, I'm way, much higher above you than anybody else's rightly,
you know, it's just the nature of things, you know, in terms of power,
probably not. Or at least, you know, before she became ruler of other worlds,
she's nowhere near above apocalypse,
but even apocalypse plays it a little Hottie. Right.
He's like answering me before, you know, explain yourself before I become angry.
He's literally in the, in the he's in the lion's den, right?
He's in the belly of the beast. What is he going to do? Like there's no power.
He possesses that could overcome Saturday.
He could just start like smashing the 20 lights Citadel, right? Just like,
you know, smashing his fist and knocking off giant chunks of it.
And just more or less like inconveniencing her. But that would be about it.
That'd be about all that he could do in this situation.
But one of the things that she says is she's like, I'm kind of intrigued by you.
You really are the oldest beans in existence, right? In, in, on your earth,
not across your entire universe, right. Relative to the history of the universe.
You're but a spec while you've been,
you've been alive for a fraction of a second.
But in terms of the history of your earth,
you've been around for a relatively lengthy amount of time. I mean,
even within the history of the earth, right,
it's still kind of a fraction of a second,
but in comparison to the evolution of your race of mutant kind,
you've been around for a long, long time.
And even in comparison to the length of humanity,
you've been around for a pretty lengthy amount of time, but I'm interested.
I'm kind of curious about you had all this power that you possess,
you beat Morgan Lafaye right. In like a straight up battle. That's interesting.
But what you've done here is you bullied yourself in,
you basically played the role of somebody who's lesser than yourself.
And then when it was, once it was all said and done,
the only reason you even got here is because I invited you.
So ask yourself the question.
Is it kind of an insult to know that no matter what your best efforts were,
you only got in here because I allowed it,
but even kind of continuing this taunting. And even when he says like,
are you trying to provoke me at the end of the day,
she still just kind of plays it fast and loose and she still doesn't really take
him, take him seriously more so than that. She's like, you're a very,
very old being. I'm surprised that you're acting so impatient here.
You really shouldn't be acting this impatient.
Like you've been around long enough.
You should have more patients than almost anybody else here.
You're playing a game that you've been working on from a Linea and here at the
finish line, you're going to suddenly grow impatient. Well,
the funny thing about this is that it reveals the very human side of apocalypse
in the sense of, of course he does, like, he's about done,
like which one of us doesn't find our second wind when we're that close to the
finish line, right? That's kind of where he is, you know,
this kind of new method, this new step of,
of zealousness this going on with this character.
And so with Saturday and who was already on her way to a meeting,
she invites apocalypse along.
And this is one of those things where it seems to be kind of designed to more or
less play games. But when he enters into this meeting room,
he's met by an individual who is wearing,
what's basically the helmet of EMyth, the helmet, the helmet of this,
of this demon entity. And as we explained in the last video,
those individuals who wear it become the voice of Amazon itself.
I really say itself because we don't really know if this demon is like a man or
a woman or anything about them whatsoever,
but they basically become the person or kind of stand in as the person who's
leading this whole force. Right?
And so this person that she's meeting with is effectively the person who's
leading, the four horsemen who in turn are leading the army of Amman, right?
So this person is basically apocalypse enemy because we,
we know do by virtue of the various swords.
And who's going to be fighting who that apocalypse is destined to fight this
person. And when this person goes and removes their mask,
we one see the card of apocalypse that says the lovers and then to it's
apocalypse, his wife it's Genesis. This means that during the tournament,
apocalypse is going to have to fight and he's going to have to kill his wife.
This is a bold move by Saturday, because if it does arrive, say for example,
the Genesis is a turncoat. Say, for example,
that she's operating under this role,
but isn't actually allied with Ammon or her children,
the four horsemen and is actually working directly alongside apocalypse.
Because remember they had that conversation before she went to the portal,
prepare the world for what's coming.
If she really has maintained her solitude all the time.
And she really is a good guy all this time, then things could pop off fast.
It could pop off so quickly and go South. So astronomically fast, right?
There's there's no telling what's going to happen here, but I know it.
I know it doesn't seem overly surprised.
Like I know it doesn't seem like this great, big, huge, crazy grandiose event,
but this right here could easily turn into the turn of the tide and everything.
Saturday is built, can come crashing down. But with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments explained to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light. Now we'll catch you all later. Please.
[Inaudible].